i didn't bring a notebook i'm not sure
i'm ready for a
university lecture
[Music]
series 10 what i have called in the past
my favorite series involving
my favorite doctor peter capaldi that
doesn't mean it's my favorite series of
new who but
out of his run i think it's the best or
at least i have
up to this point we'll see what a
rewatch does and we open with
the pilot there's a lot to like here
first of all i love the setup i love the
doctor
as a college professor specifically this
doctor
and there's a lot especially you know
going back on a re-watch and knowing
what the deal with the vault is why he's
stuck on earth
that adds some context but i really love
the idea that
he can't just be gallivanting around
time and space anymore
but he's still going to want to show off
how smart he is
he's still going to want an audience and
so he
he gets himself set up so that he can
just go on these
rambling lectures about physics or
poetry
and they're the same because of the
rhymes and just
just do whatever he wants just well a
little bit
show off but also just feel
like somebody's listening this stalked
most doctors this doctor particularly
does need that
feedback he needs that input and as
somebody uh who
has and will hopefully one day again be
a
live performer uh yeah no i i get that
if you can get a live audience freaking
do it
um if you're like me anyways
and maybe that's one more thing that
this doctor and i have in common now
normally
you know he has a companion to perform
too and yes it's not
only one person not a crowd but you get
that closer connection
he doesn't have that so he'll settle for
a room full of people with much
with a much shallower connection but
then he spots bill
i love the reason that he singles bill
out i just i love that explanation
where you know she said why me and he
says
well most people when they don't
understand something they frown you
smile if that's such a small thing but
yeah that's totally the sort of thing
you'd notice
so i love that i also like bill a lot
i think that pro mackie brings a lot of
very
wonderful grounded sensibilities to her
and
while and they do a such a fine delicate
balance here that like this is an
element of bill
that i could get why it wouldn't work
for some people and under normal
circumstances it wouldn't work for me
but for some reason it does i don't know
if it's just the line delivery or the
chemistry between the actors i don't
know
but they decide to have her ask all
these questions that are the kinds of
things
fans would ask that the show
deliberately doesn't
address you know things like well why
does this
look like this why is this this or like
the one that off the top my head
you can't be from another planet tardis
as an acronym only makes sense in
english which is true
and the doctor going people usually
don't bring that
up and that's a kind of character trait
that normally would bother me this sort
of meta
lampshade hanging but the thing is it
doesn't feel like it's
jammed in to try and make a commentary
about the
show or these things it feels like a
character trait she
she thinks about things that other
people think about but she just
she grabs on to details that are a
little bit different from other people
she comes with things slightly sideways
and that throws off the doctor a little
bit like how long it takes her to
finally say it's bigger on the inside
and the outside and i love that naruto
punctuates that with hey we got there
oh and also nardole's back and i am he's
he's balanced now he is what i mean
there's there's one toilet gag
but other than that this is what i want
him to be where he has a rapport with
the doctor
he's trying to basically be the doctor's
keeper but he's a little bit
around people i i like that but he he's
not
he's not weird and awkward around the
doctor any more than you know he just
is as a as an entity but he's he's got a
more established thing going with
capaldi's doctor which i love
much more than the last well certainly
the first time we saw him and even more
than last time we saw him
this really feels well established and i
always like that
as fun as it can be to watch a
relationship build i have a lot of fun
coming in on something that
feels like it's already been there for a
while i like
the feeling of well-established rapport
and i think that
nardole and the doctor have that they
have a pretty good grip on each other
and what's going on
um so all right this is this is a
fairly minor thing but i'm going to
bring it up because it did bug me
um the the whole thing so bill
the doctor says you know why are you in
my class um
when you're not actually a student and
bill goes on this rambling story about
serving chips to this girl in the
canteen
and basically giving her extra chips
because she was
attracted to her and that girl ended up
gaining weight now
on the one hand i like that bill doesn't
really have an answer and tells this
rambling
story basically hoping that going
through this train of thought will lead
somewhere cause
i'm not gonna say i do that often but i
relate
but on the other hand there's like
there's one specific line
it's sentence in that thing that really
does bother me
i don't have a problem with the nature
of the story i don't even have a problem
with the fact that
bill seems mildly taken aback at the
fact that this
girl is now fat i mean you know
everybody has a type
that they're attracted to i do however
take issue with the fact that she states
less life in it beautiful chips as
if beauty and
weight from comfort and being anything
other than a specifically prescribed
size are
polar opposites you're either beautiful
or you're fat
um like she doesn't say that outright
but the way that sentence lands and the
way it's framed
and even though you like she softens it
slightly after that by going
i like chips and so did she like that
takes the curse off it a little bit but
not completely i just don't like
that like that line really rubs me the
wrong way but it is only one line
in the thing so let's actually get the
plot of this
which is a pretty solid plot as far as
uh companion introductory stories go
because ultimately
the primary purpose of the story is to
introduce bill and set up the status quo
as it currently exists at the start of
this series and it has to do all that
while also
telling a story and it's a pretty it's a
pretty
good idea to have it be effectively a
chase
story because that allows you to get it
stripped down and not have to bog it in
too many specific details because
ultimately
how are we propelling this narrative
forward once the plot actually kicks in
well this thing is coming after us we're
trying to run away
awesome that is a naturally propelled
forward-moving
plot that does not require that we get
bogged down in a ton of stuff
so i i dig that i think that was a good
call
there's some elements of
heather as a character that
i'm a little bit up and down on it's
actually
it's handled slightly better than my
memory of it
but i'm still a little my memory of it
and part of this actually also has to do
with my memory of how it comes back at
the end of the series so we'll see how
well that
uh my memory on that actually holds up
but
the the whole thing of it my memory was
that it pushed this idea that
bill and heather made this instant deep
connection and that was what drew them
together
and there's that as kind of an
underlying implication but this episode
does actually provide a more logistical
answer
so that people like me who are grumpy
buggers who hate romantic subplots
especially when it hinges on the idea of
true love that is established in a very
short period of time
because i hate that there is the
offering of
just before heather died and was
absorbed
by this puddle this sentient fuel
that the last thing that she had said
the last thing in her mind
was this promise to bill because bill
you know
all bill is going to do is like go
around the building and come around and
see her and says
you promise you won't run away and
heather says i promise
so for someone like me who
look it's not that i don't like
emotional storytelling it's not even
that i don't like romance but it's not
why i'm here
and i hate i hate people taking romance
and trying to cash that check for more
than it's worth
and i think the idea of this like oh
their feelings are so strong they're
drawn together that absolutely would be
that so offering up this logistical
explanation
that's not to say you can't believe that
their connection was so strong
and so immediate and so deep you can
still believe that but i don't have to
and for me
that helps a lot but there is ultimately
still the
fact that heather is not particularly
well fleshed out
and the little bits we get about her
like she's i mean she's cute
but like she also she and bill and the
few times they actually talk to each
other don't seem to have an awful lot in
common
so part of me is like what what is
pulling you towards her but then i have
to remind myself how young bill is be
and get out of my own damn near 40
headspace
and remember that yeah yeah in
your early 20s that is a time where you
just kind of leap into things based off
a vibe
or even just raw attraction whereas
now at my age i would look at something
like that and go well i mean like yeah
you're cute but i'm not
like there's nothing jiben here we've
talked and like
you've said almost the exact opposite of
everything i said and i'm old enough to
know that the opposite
track thing that's no you gotta you
gotta connect somewhere but you know
they're in their 20s so you know what i
can let that go too
there is of course the inherent issue of
you know this does factor in some ways
into
the barrier gays trope because
i mean heather is established to at
least be open to an attraction to
bill and is uh basically killed
as soon as she indicates that she might
actually be open to
starting something serious and even
though it's not as an egregious case of
barrier
that as barrier gaze often is because
she is not 100 of the queer population
of this episode because bill's still
around
it is still uh it is still fifty percent
of the known queer populace of the
episode and in addition to that
it is it does bother me that basically
as
soon as it is established that
maybe there is something between these
two now she's dead
like uh the timing of that that irks me
as for the fuel itself it's a neat
concept and the
the execution of it really feels like an
amalgam of
like three different things because um
to some degree it's kind of
got the um the lodger thing with that
spaceship that needed a pilot
and you know and it's taking the drives
and the instincts of
the pilot to that and that is
determining some of what it's doing
so that's at play visually it's very
reminiscent of the flood
from waters of mars especially when we
see heather just standing there just
dripping
under that dark tree when bill uh you
know first sees her after she dies
and then it's pulling on midnight for a
certain extent as well because
once she has become whatever the heck
you want to call it
that she is all she's doing is mimicking
now that's actually pretty well played
later
when bill releases her and says her
goodbyes that she says a line and then
heather says it back in it
even though the words are the same the
meaning becomes different because of the
delivery that's actually really well
done and i do like that but
it is just kind of a mashup of three
existing
um ideas and concepts shoved into one
thing
and i mean it works well enough i do
like that
while there is the visual nod to the
flood i like that there was a higher
emphasis on the
audio that you know she's wrong because
you
hear dripping whereas um
waters of mars was like there weren't a
lot of
drips definitely not audio level
generally if the water was there it was
flooding in so here to have it just be
this
you know that that little single sounds
of water dropping like ooh
that's actually a good audio cue to
create tension and it's the kind of
thing that you can lay into the
background
ahead of when the characters notice it
see if the audience catches it first
and that so that's that's well done and
and i dig that for the most part
i do have to wonder like with fuel that
is like this it does feel like a little
bit of a
of an overpowered thing for lack of a
better way to put it it's like
this is the kind of technology that
seems
so incredibly potent like it can
follow the tardis all the way through
time and space
at will and it just leaked out of a
spaceship like just a normal spaceship
so far as we can tell
okay i mean like i
roll with it okay but it is one of those
things that's like how common is this
like it's it's fuel more or less
how common is this that we have like
this seems like such a leap in
technology from anything else that we've
seen and it's like so advanced and yet
it's such a common thing like fuel is a
common item
and generally if you're talking about
any piece of technology
lots of things will run on the same fuel
and like how many things have this kind
of
potent power behind them i don't know
that's thinking about it too much though
honestly within the confines of the
episode
it works it certainly does this episode
has a lot of also has a lot of really
fun
small nods that i appreciate i love the
the little pencil jar full of sonic
screwdrivers i
love the picture of susan i like that
there's a picture of river on his desk
those are great especially because like
those are the kinds of things you'd
expect
someone to just have on their work desk
but to us as the audience if we
recognize these characters i mean
i would expect most to recognize river
but especially if you recognize susan oh
that has and that's sweet and i love
that oh you know what
there's this little moment between the
interaction with the doctrine bill that
i love and it reminded me of ace in the
terms of
not putting up with the doctors crap
because
you know the doctor and bill have been
bantering for a little bit and
um bill says something the effect of i
always wanted to be at this
university and the doctor gets mocking
where he gets a little mean he says what
are you doing at this university i
always wanted to come here yeah
just have chips so anyway
am i nearly done i love that it's
without making a big scene without being
like
hey you can't talk to me like that i
still get that sense of strength from
her like
that is just great to see and it's
it's really well delivered in the line
delivery and just the nature of that
interaction just small pause
we finished and like oh there was there
was a lot of strike from that little
pause and that line delivery that was
good i like it
uh we get the introduction of the vault
which you know it's this season's
or series is um mystery box
yeah i do i mean i'll i'll jump ahead a
little bit i do like that we get the
answer to what's in the vault
fairly well ahead of the actual finale
of the series i appreciate that as a
shake up but it is still planting the
same mystery book
ooh don't you wonder what's in the
just tell me a story don't give me this
friggin dangle of carrot if you're
telling me a good story i want to stick
around regardless
you shouldn't have to have me sticking
around just to solve a mystery
especially when the answers usually
aren't that interesting so i don't i
don't
like that it's there as a setup but as
far as the mystery boxes goes
i don't find it especially egregious in
the scope of these things oh
you know it's another thing and i had
totally forgotten this
in the next time on doctor who they did
this isn't super uncommon
not just for doctor who for shows like
this in general that have shot their
entire
seasons or series before the first
episode airs
they it's not a next time next episode
it's like show stuff from across the
whole series
and they spoil john sim as the master
and that next time i completely
forgotten that they did that
and shame on them for it the hell
i think that's everything oh there's
some really nice laying for stuff that
is definitely gonna
matter later when they they first get
into the tardis and the
the doctor says um you'll you're safe in
here and i promise you always will be
so there's that and also i love the
like this kind of epitomizes why
capaldi in series 10 is my favorite of
his take on the doctrine why i feel like
the doctor has settled uh into where he
should be because
like i've said this before series eight
he was very standoffish in grumpy
series nine he seemed like he was trying
too hard to be cool
series 10 he feels free to be silly
it feels like he's he's let his both his
guard and his facade down
so there's moments like bill asking
what's the sky made of and the doctor
says lemon drops
really no but wouldn't that be something
it's just this wonderful
small silly moment i'm like oh this is
you being
comfortable and i'm really happy seeing
cavaldi's doctor comfortable after
everything else he's been through
the pilot solid start to what is to my
memory a solid series
have you rewatched it lately what'd you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something on down in the
comments
let's talk about it usual stuff like
share subscribe there's a patreon that
helps cover my
bills and ensure that this channel
continues to be up and
running in addition to that there is of
course the usual stuff the likes the
shares the subscribes i have merch i am
on other social media
check them out or don't
you don't have to end of the day you are
the council and i'm just running the
meetings
until next time this council is
[Music]
adjourned
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um